The more common deployment strategy for
network IDS is to deploy
them as passive sensors.
A passive sensor only takes
a copy of the traffic.
That is, the traffic continues
to reach it's destination
without passing through the device.
Therefore, from the point of
view of network performance,
a passive sensor does not add
any overhead to network traffic.
This illustrates a typical
passive sensor configuration.
The sensor connects to
the network transmission medium,
such as a ethernet cable,
through a direct physical tap.
The tap provides the sensor with
a copy of all network traffic
being carried by the medium.
The network interface card for
this tab usually does not have
an IP address configured for it.
Therefore, all traffic into
this network interface card
is simply collected with no protocol
interaction with the network.
The sensor has a second
network interface card
that connects to the network
with an IP address so
that it can communicate with
a backhand management server.